[Musique]
on recommence
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
bravo
merci pour cette belle
œuvre collective
inattendue
je vous parle maintenant d'une oeuvre
individuelle
la vôtre
chacune chacun d'entre vous la vôtre
Confucius vous connaissez
choisissez un métier ou un travail que
vous aimez et vous n'aurez pas à
travailler un seul jour de votre vie
il avait raison Confucius il avait
d'autant plus raison que les experts
prévoient que les jeunes changeront
d'activité ou de métiers entre 13 et 15
fois dans leur vie professionnelle ils
ont donc de plus en plus souvent
l'occasion de changer et de choisir une
des composantes les plus importantes de
nos vies
je peux vous en parler j'ai été gâté
j'ai exercé différents métiers que j'ai
à chaque fois choisi et qui m'ont donné
le sentiment de me réaliser pleinement
mon regard sur ma réussite entre
guillemets était très positif
il était très aligné sur celui de mes
parents
un peu moins sur celui de mes enfants
eux souhaitaient et souhaitent toujours
un monde moins pollué plus équitable
plus humain
ils ont raison mon regard sur la
réussite dans la vie ou plutôt la
réussite de sa vie évolue change avec
mes enfants avec le temps nous sommes en
2012 il y a 10 ans je dirige alors le
centre des congrès parc exposition
d'Agen une belle petite ville dans le
Sud-Ouest ou située
mi-chemin de Bordeaux Toulouse
ville moyenne agréable comparable à
Belfort peut-être un petit peu plus
agréable que Belfort
agents donc on organise une des
premières manifestations en France sur
le thème du bien-être au travail je fais
témoigner des chefs d'entreprise qui
mettent en œuvre des bonnes pratiques
des nouvelles pratiques de management
innovants dans leurs entreprises ils
viennent témoigner de transformation
humaine qu'il constate dans leurs
organisations des salariés plus plus
créatifs plus engagés de meilleurs
résultats une meilleure ambiance il
témoigne aussi souvent de d'effets
positifs des faits tangibles positifs
sur leur vie personnelle bah ouais nos
vies personnelles et professionnelles
sont étroitement liés comment aller très
bien dans l'une si l'on n'est pas bien
dans l'autre et inversement
j'ai adoré organisé planifier développer
inaugurer un tas de manifestation
une activité intense excitante
enivrantes même parfois pourtant de
cette activité passionnante des
souvenirs qu'il me reste de cette
période
ce sont plutôt mes colères souvent
disproportionnés brutale des coups de
gueule injustes dont je suis aujourd'hui
encore honteux des paroles déplacées que
j'ai pu envoyer comme ça et je me
souviendrai toujours
du jour et de l'endroit
où un de mes fils vient me dire comme ça
d'adulte et adulte alors qu'il a 11 ou
12 ans tu sais papa nous ce qu'on
préfère c'est quand tu es heureux
je lui dois à mon fils ma seconde vie
celle où je ne dois plus d'abord réussir
à force de conviction d'énergie de
résultats mais celle où je dois d'abord
essayer d'être heureux
il me faut
identifier
et pratiquer ce qui me rend heureux
alors je prends un peu de recul
j'écris je deviens auteur formateur
conférencier mon thème principal et
ne plus organiser le travail en fonction
des fiches de poste ou des process mais
l'organiser ce travail dès que possible
en fonction des talents des personnes
ce qu'elles aiment faire et qu'elles
font bien parce qu'elles y trouvent de
la réalisation d'elle-même et du plaisir
ce n'est pas tant que ce soit plus
agréable c'est que c'est plus efficace
ça a été étudié mesuré prouver démontrer
alors bien sûr on peut pas le faire
partout bien sûr on ne peut pas le faire
tout le temps mais quand on peut le
faire
faisons-le
oui alors tu sais Gilles nous on n'a pas
vraiment de talent
toi tu es comme trois Français sur 4 tu
ne sais pas mettre des mots sur tes
talents parce qu'on ne nous a pas appris
à le faire ni à l'école ni au collège ni
au lycée ni en fac encore trop peu dans
les entreprises celles et ceux qui parmi
vous ont vécu aux États-Unis savent
combien c'est une question de culture
nous ici ce dont on se rappelle c'est
nos défauts à ça nos défauts on les
connaît on nous les a assez rappelés
depuis l'enfance
on a tous autour de nous des personnes
dont on pense qu'elles auraient dû ou
qu'elles auraient pu développer un
talent qu'on a détecté en elle et on se
dit même que c'est vachement dommage
qu'elle n'est pas développée ça vous
parle ça
pour le plus grand nombre de ces
personnes on ne le ramène jamais dit
qu'elles avaient ce talent qu'on a
détecté en elle et ben vous savez quoi
les autres
pour vos talents à vous
pareil
le plus souvent et ne voulons pas dit
alors toi tu vas aller voir tes proches
tu vas leur demander eux savent pour
quelles activités tuent le plus douée
ils le savent parce que si à chaque fois
il te demande à toi de le faire c'est
parce qu'ils savent que pour toi c'est
beaucoup plus facile que pour eux et
pourquoi tu te rends pas compte toi pas
parce que tu es dans ta zone de facilité
de plaisir ta zone de talent et si tu le
voulais vraiment tu pourrais te
démarquer avec ça dans ton boulot faire
la différence les études à propos des
modèles d'excellence démontre qu'une
personne qui connaît bien ses talents et
son mode opératoire cognitif son mode
opératoire cognitif
cette personne là va jusqu'à quadruplés
sa capacité de travail et ça et son
efficacité
quadruplé qu'est-ce qu'on attend
est-ce que vous avez déjà vu une
personne réussir dans la vie dans les
affaires ou dans quoi que ce soit en
s'appuyant sur ses faiblesses c'est
lacunes
qu'est-ce qu'elles ont fait celles et
ceux qui ont réussi qu'est-ce qu'ils ont
fait c'est ceux qui ont réussi ils se
sont
focaliser sur un de leurs talent ils
l'ont travaillé développé et leur
réussite est toujours étroitement liée à
ce talent
Beethoven ne faisait que de la musique
Zidane
que du foot Bigflo et Oli que du rap
c'est ce que j'appelle le DPP le
développement personnel personnel on
développe ses talents à soi et ça marche
à tous les coups pourquoi ça donne de
très bons résultats à tous les coups
pourquoi parce que c'est plus simple
plus facile plus rapide de développer
ses talons à soi que de devoir apprendre
et comprendre pour les pour les
développer des techniques et des outils
dont on ne sait pas toujours d'ailleurs
d'où exactement d'où elles viennent
pour moi le développement personnel
c'est d'abord se connaître soi et là je
n'invente rien merci Socrate et c'est
aussi
et plus souvent utilisé ce que l'on a en
soi c'est qualités ses émotions ses
envies envies être vivant donc avec ces
faiblesses et avec ces dites-le avec moi
dites le fort avec
C ah bah vous le saviez déjà alors
question
et là normalement vous faites ah parce
que vous allez apprendre quelque chose
question
de nombreux menteurs ou consultants
sont légitimes parce qu'ils ont surmonté
des épreuves
OK
ils peuvent nous dire des solutions des
conseils parce qu'ils sont sortis OK
devons-nous faire évoluer nos vies avec
les solutions à leurs problèmes des
autres ou avec nos solutions et nos
atouts à nous
application
lorsque vous sollicitez vos proches vos
collègues vos collaboratrices vos
collaborateurs pensez à vos enfants
quand vous leur donnez à vos enfants à
faire quelque chose que vous savez
qu'ils aiment faire ils le font bien
ils le font jusqu'au bout ça leur est
agréable vous ne leur donnez pas du
boulot vous leur faites un cadeau vous
joignez justement l'agréable à l'utile
super
solution
ouais là ça sent la fin et on va avoir
des outils concrets on va pouvoir y
aller là
les
la douzaine d'outils d'exercices que
nous propose les neurosciences la
psychologie positive et d'autres
disciplines pour mettre des mots sur nos
talents parmi tous ces outils il y en a
un qui s'appelle les bonheurs de
l'enfant génial très révélateur pourquoi
parce que nos talents sont ancrés en
nous depuis le plus jeune âge il ne
demande qu'à être révélé
et un de mes bonheurs d'enfance à moi
c'est quand je jouais à animer des
émissions de radio
quand on partait en vacances en famille
dans la voiture je m'amusais à animer
comment ça s'appelait la valise RTL vous
vous souvenez je leur faisais gagner des
cadeaux ils étaient contents et moi tu
penses j'étais aux anges et puis aussi
en famille il y avait souvent à la fin
des repas au moment où il faut commencer
à débarrasser la table j'avais envie
d'aller aux toilettes
je sais pas si on a à qui ça parle
les toilettes étaient juste à côté de la
cuisine
j'adorais dans cette petite pièce
entendre raisonner ma voix
alors je laissais la porte ouverte pour
qu'il m'entende et je faisais des
interviews alors comment ça s'est passé
le repas ce soir et ben écoutez très
très bien c'était très bon la cuisinière
en plus a eu la bonne idée d'ajouter des
haricots en plus des pommes de terre
alors c'était excellent et blablabli et
bla bla bla mes frères et sœurs m'ont
reproché des dizaines de fois de ne pas
les aider à ranger la table mes parents
je crois jamais
50 ans plus tard écoutez bien
j'avais 10 ans quand je faisais des
émissions de radio dans les toilettes
j'ai aujourd'hui presque 60 ans 50 ans
plus tard un des participants à ma
dernière journée bien-être au travail
viens me confier qu'il va lancer bientôt
une nouvelle radio nationale
il va me dit-il mettre en place une
radio il me propose d'y participer
il m'explique que les Français
reprochent à leur média deux choses trop
de publicités trop d'informations
négatives et anxiogènes nous allons me
dit-il aider les Français à vivre mieux
j'ai de la chance tous les jours
maintenant d'accueillir à l'antenne des
personnes des femmes des hommes qui sont
tous plus inspirants les uns que les
autres et qui viennent présenter leurs
bonnes pratiques
ils viennent présenter leurs bonnes
pratiques et ses fantastique de les
avoir avec eux parce que il y a à chaque
fois une conviction qui passe une
énergie et vous savez ce qu'ils disent
le plus souvent
c'est qu'ils ont eu la chance qu'ils ont
eu de la chance ou qu'ils ont de la
chance alors que la chance ne l'aurait
pas tombé dessus comme ça
ils se sont bougés ils se sont ils ont
passé à l'action alors je vous propose
de passer à l'action un mettez des mots
sur vos talents
il y a plein d'exercices pour ça et ça
marche 2 utiliser vos talents tous les
jours pratiquer les ça rend heureux
trois
utilisez les talons des autres vous leur
faites des cadeaux et ils sont plus
efficaces ça marche
et soyez sympa dites-leur leur talent
vous savez
de plus en plus souvent je me dis à qui
aujourd'hui ai-je dit qu'il avait un
talent parce que c'est peut-être ça qui
a moi ne me coûte rien mais qui à lui ou
à elle va lui donner l'énergie de mettre
en oeuvre ce talent et ça va enjoliver
sa vie et ça va aussi enjoliver la
mienne alors allez-y mettez-vous aussi à
ce pas de côté
utilisez le DPP
parce que sinon
vous allez lui répondre quoi à la grosse
voix du dernier jour quand elle va vous
dire et toi
qu'as-tu fait des talents que je t'ai
donné
tu n'as rien compris au DPP
je vous aurai prévenu